buongiorno a tutti e grazie per
l'accoglienza
si ricomincia dal cuore perché ogni
volta che la mia vita mi ha costretto a
farlo ho capito che era veramente quello
da cui la nostra essenza quello da cui
dovevo ricominciare e grazie al cuore ho
imparato delle elezioni fondamentali
infatti proprio per questo che lo
considero il luogo principale che ha
ospitato la mia crescita
quella interiore avevo 19 anni e pensavo
di essere una ragazza come tutte le
altre
se stavo di essere immortale a 19 anni
in realtà il mio corpo mi stava dando
una serie di segnali che però non ero
ancora in grado di capire fino a che non
sono diventati dei segnali così forti
che non potevo più fare finta di non
vederli ho cominciato ad avere dei
dolori fortissimi alla schiena che mi
hanno costretto dapprima sulla sedia a
rotelle e poi a letto paralizzata ma la
cosa peggiore che nessuno capiva cosa
avessi finché un giorno è arrivato un
medico che ha capito e mi ha detto che
aveva una sindrome rara ormonale che
aiutata da un tumore alla surrenale
destra
quel giorno festeggiato è strana la vita
avrai sempre pensato che quella era la
notizia peggiore che potesse mai
ricevere in realtà quel giorno si è
trasformata in una gioia perché perché
ho capito l'importanza della
consapevolezza sapere contro cosa dovevo
combattere finalmente mi aveva permesso
di cominciare a farlo e così ho iniziato
un percorso sicuramente difficile dove
non sono mancate
le sofferenze le paure timori di non
farcela
e allora ho scoperto un'altra un altro
valore importante quello
dell'accettazione ho imparato che
accettando i miei limiti
le mie paure pressione i miei dolori
diventavano meno forti e io riuscivo a
combattere meglio e quindi ho iniziato
ad accettare tutto quello che mi stava
succedendo
senza paura ma con la consapevolezza di
quello che dovevo fare
mentre sono stata operata e ricominciavo
e ho cominciato un importante percorso
di riabilitazione non soltanto fisica ma
anche e soprattutto psicologica
proprio perché questa malattia mi aveva
dato una serie di disturbi legati anche
alla psiche è subentrata un'altra
malattia un morbo raro di crohn legato
all'intestino che appunto una malattia
cronica
questo perché riconosciuta dalla
medicina come psicosomatica e che è
andato a verificare ulteriormente
l'importanza che aveva la mente il fatto
di quanto la mente fosse legata in
maniera indissolubile al corpo
ho imparato l'importanza della
cognizione intesa come capire quali sono
i nostri sentimenti che cosa ci sta
dicendo il nostro cuore non dobbiamo mai
sottovalutare quello che sentiamo o non
prendersene cura
ho iniziato un percorso che continua
ancora oggi di cura della mia mente e di
quello che sento
a quel punto avevo raggiunto uno strano
primato era un paziente decisamente
speciale che gli ospedali si
contendevano una malattia rara una
rarissima nel giro di pochi mesi ma in
realtà non sapevamo ancora quanto fossi
speciale come paziente qualche mese dopo
in realtà un paio di mesi dopo una
mattina all'improvviso mi sono svegliata
perché non respiravo più questa volta
sulla diagnosi non c'erano stati dubbi
cardiomiopatia dilatativa fulminante un
nome complicato per un meccanismo
piuttosto semplice
il cuore che ha un muscolo svolge le sue
funzioni vitali contraente
nel momento in cui non riesce più a
farlo perché non è più tonico smette di
fare il suo compito e questo a una serie
di implicazioni piuttosto importanti ci
si capiscono fin da subito non puoi più
camminare non puoi respirare non puoi
più mangiare dormire
di fronte alla situazione così
paradossale persino per i medici mi sono
guardata dentro e mi sono chiesta questa
che dovrei fare per sopravvivere in
questo momento come ti stai sentendo e
mi sono sentita come in uno di quei
videogiochi dove per sopravvivere devi
passare i vari livelli più vanno avanti
i livelli e più le porte le prove
diventano difficili e ho capito che la
mia strategia di sopravvivenza stava
proprio lì nel prenderla con un gioco
con leggerezza
sì perché più le situazioni sono
difficili più è necessario avere un
atteggiamento leggero poiché la
drammaticità e già implicita nella
situazione stessa e continuare ad auto
con commiserarsi a chiedersi perché a me
perché sta succedendo tutto questo ti
toglie soltanto tantissima energia di
cui più che mai bisogno in quei momenti
e quindi ho cominciato a vivere questa
esperienza con un approccio leggero
scherzandoci sopra sdrammatizzando su
tutto sulla mia malattia sulla mia morte
su qualunque cosa e mi sono resa conto
che più lo facevo e più stavo bene è
arrivato poi il verdetto mi hanno
comunicato che le cure non funzionavano
e quindi che dovevo entrare in lista
io che ancora vent'anni non avevo capito
la gravità della situazione ho risposto
candidamente ma eletta ricordo di
trapianto
un metodo che è stato come ricevere un
forte schiaffo
ho pianto un giorno e poi ha deciso che
quella era la mia sfida da vincere
la vita voleva giocare ok io ero pronta
a farlo ma lo volevo fare e l'altra
grande lezione che ho imparato è la
volontà dentro di noi abbiamo una forza
interiore che spesso minimamente ci
immaginiamo ma dobbiamo avere la voglia
di tirarla fuori
e così ho fatto sono stata operata
ho ricevuto il mio primo cuore donato
dopo poco più di un mese di attesa sono
stata molto fortunata
il trapianto è magia non è un solo
l'intervento e la vita che si trasforma
e che vince sulla morte ma è anche un
compromesso non è mai guarigione non si
torna indietro si rimane trapiantati per
tutta la vita e quando esci da lì devi
fare i conti con una nuova versione di
te stesso
una versione che non è tanto per quello
che sono le cicatrici o le cure che
dovrai fare ma per quella consapevolezza
della bellezza della vita
dell'importanza delle piccole cose e
così ti rendi conto che è necessario
semplificare la tua vita perché alcune
persone alcune situazioni non possono
comprendere quello che sei diventato e
quindi le devi lasciare andare a volte
può sembrare impossibile possono volerci
degli anni è sempre doloroso ma
necessario se vogliamo prenderci cura di
noi nel nostro cuore della nostra vita
la malattia mi aveva regalato una cosa
bellissima
la fiducia in me stessa mi ero resa
conto che potevo davvero superare
qualunque cosa e avevo la mia vita
davanti quella che era rimasta in stand
by per un anno la vita di una ventenne e
quindi ho fatto tutto quello che volevo
ma con più cuore e finalmente con una
grande fiducia in me stessa pensa
di aver imparato già molto ma in realtà
dieci anni dopo ho cominciato a
risentire delle sensazioni che purtroppo
conoscevo molto bene ma che inizialmente
fingevo di di non sapere che cosa
fossero in realtà era subentrato un
nuovo problema di salute una rigetto
cronico molto grave
attualmente incurabile nei pazienti
giovani hanno provato comunque per un
anno a curarmi in tutti i modi ma niente
sono dovuto tornare lista di trapianto
per la seconda volta ed è stato diverso
ero molto arrabbiata ha vent'anni e più
facile accettare gli imprevisti e vedere
la tua vita invece a 30 che si sgretola
un'altra volta dopo tutti i sacrifici no
ero davvero arrabbiata le probabilità
che arrivasse quella secondo cuore erano
praticamente nulle come dicevano i miei
medici un ago in un pagliaio
ma quel lago è arrivato e la vita mi ha
insegnato un altro grande valore
il perdono sì ho perdonato la vita e ho
iniziato il continuo a farlo a imparare
a perdonare anche gli altri e me stessa
insieme a questo grande insegnamento del
perdono è arrivato quello della
gratitudine
sì ma gratitudine immensa per la seconda
volta la vita mi aveva permesso di
tornare alla mia vita di prima mi aveva
permesso di continuare quella vita per
cui tanto stavo lottando e questa
gratitudine era così immensa che non
potevo tenerlo solo per me era mio
dovere restituirle agli altri e allora
ho scoperto che condividendo la mia
storia aiutavo le persone quindi dovevo
farlo
a quel punto quando sono uscito
dall'ospedale
ho chiesto le mie migliori amiche che
sono state il pilastro della mia
battaglia sempre presenti in prima linea
se te lo sentivano di fondare
un'associazione di beneficenza insieme a
me quali 3.0 facile immaginare perché il
3.0 perché voleva essere innovativa una
piccola oggi onlus innovativa che si
basava proprio su tutti questi
insegnamenti che avevo ricevuto e che
considero i grandi doni della malattia e
quindi abbiamo iniziato a parlare di
donazione di sensibilizzare più persone
possibili in modo leggero
parlando nella dove non te lo sperti
durante un concerto a una festa durante
una mostra d'arte proprio perché la
drammaticità della donazione già
implicita in sé
bisogna morire per donare gli organi lo
sappiamo quindi perché aggiungerne
parliamone in maniera leggera questo
riso sulla bocca lo stesso atteggiamento
che avevamo avuto noi
nell'affrontare la malattia e la
condivisione
sì oggi abbiamo creato una piccola
piccola o grande community sia reale che
virtuale di tante persone che hanno
vissuto la stessa esperienza o
esperienze simili e hanno deciso di
condividerle e questa condivisione ci
aiuta a stare meglio a sentirsi meno
soli e aiuta anche a me perché ogni
volta che racconto la mia storia
lei lavoro meglio e imparo di più questi
valori li assimila sempre di più quindi
si sono estremamente grata alle mie
malattie perché mi hanno costretto a
guardarmi dentro e mi hanno regalato la
possibilità di riconnettere mi con me
stessa col mio corpo con il mio cuore
con la mia mente e in definitiva mi
hanno decisamente dato molto più di
quello che mi hanno tolto regalandomi
questo grande insegnante
che la felicità non è una questione di
fortuna e felicità la scelta e della
nostra
grazie
[Applauso]